[Music]
all right welcome everybody to the
endgame class today and it's gonna be a
little bit different I have my daughter
here with me
so we're gonna go over the this game I
actually played in at the Chess Club
here in the US chess League finals
against Dallas in 2005 and my opponent
is grandmasters well he was the
International master at that time
recently so here we have a French
defense 93 so we have the you know
classical variation of the French and I
said to play Knight f6 here he responded
with Bishop g5 and now here war are my
options here I have here a few
alternatives here okay
so I would like to tell me - my
alternatives here for black yes you want
exactly you can take D takes e4 which is
the Rubenstein variation you can play
Bishop e7 the classical setup or you can
play Bishop before which is known as
it's got a really interesting name what
is the name of the bishop before line
McCutchin yeah McCutchin line mm-hmm so
I took only four now he plays 94 now
Bishop e7 I chose I also sometimes play
Knight bTW several here but here I chose
just Bishop e7 line now he goes here
Bishop takes f6 now I take back gtx f6
developing so this is all theory still
started f 593 a six you don't want to
play c5 here quickly because if you play
if I for example you're gonna be c5 is
gonna be met by a strong response d5 we
have something
let me see if I can okay
so so he played Queen e2 here again you
don't want to play c5 immediately here
because you're gonna be met by a strong
d5 okay so like if you do this this is
not gonna be good because he has a five
sorry something
so I played 86 and now he played Bishop
Queen e2
the idea is if you play c5 this is gonna
be met by d5 again so I play b5 okay let
me see if I can turn off this
coordinates because okay alright that's
fine
so I play the move b5 what is my idea
after b5 what am I trying to achieve in
this position
yes
yeah absolutely bishop before so now I
play long cause and now he is gearing up
he is giving up to play the move d5 so
this move needs to be stopped
this move has to be stopped it needs to
be prevented okay how how we are going
to do that how we are going to prevent
that yes we can play c6 but I wanted
first to attack him attack the knight to
make him move now I want to take so now
he goes here Knight to a4 now he goes
Knight to a4 and now we continue with
our development Queen d5 this move will
prevent him from playing d5 and will
activate our Queen and now we are
attacking something what are we talking
here everybody yeah
we are attacking the a to pawn queen
takes a - there are a few different
options here he chose Queen c4 if he
goes King b1 I just call 97 and continue
with Bishop Bishop d7 this is what I'm
trying to do and I go it's something
like this there should be seven and
Queen B 5 and black is black is doing
fine here okay so that's why he played
Queen to see for activating his Queen
and now proposing the exchange I don't
want to take because well if I take the
problem is here is Bishop takes and now
d5 I have to deal with which is a very
strong idea okay so d5 I have to deal
with it's very very strong idea so so
that's why I don't want to do that
so here I decided that I should just
play Bishop d7 and if he captures on d5
I go Bishop takes Bishop to d5 and again
why black wants to prevent the d5 break
in this position this is the main idea
to try to prevent d5 but okay this
involves a sacrifice okay so he takes my
pawn and it seems like wait a minute
where is the pawn
where is the pawn here now we're down
upon what are we going to do but this is
a positional positional sacrifice okay
now what should I do
what should black do in this position
then it's your one
is not
well I have to go Bishop d6 first to
attack the Queen now he goes here
now because if he goes to be 6 I have 97
so I go see like 197 just developing now
he takes Bishop takes d5
now attacking on f3 and also on a2 as
well I'm down upon here but my bishops
are very strong okay
now he goes b3 now he goes b3 now you
want I played rugby because I want to
put pressure yeah this way I'm putting
pressure must administers Tina yeah but
because they work on g8 will put
pressure on GQ
it's a niche throughout
now I played Russia because I want to
put pressure on g2 and if he develops
the bishop I can take so it's very
difficult even though he is up upon it's
very difficult for white to move now he
played 91 now he goes 31 what to do
now what should I do here
Jane Thomas
I decided to go king e7 that way I can
connect my rooks okay I mean I can't
play h5 but I think it's just better to
connect the rooks because I can play h5
a little bit later on okay now it goes
here Bishop to e2
and I cannot take for example if you
think you're going to take this it's a
problem because he's gonna take and and
rook tick so I cannot take because take
take is Bishop f3 now what should I do
yes I played rook a d8 Bishop f3 I take
if he takes with the night I take on g2
so he has ticked up the department now
his pawn structure is damaged ok and now
I go check and look at this wolf 95 now
this move actually puts him in a pretty
difficult spot here because now what to
do there is a pressure on ft there is a
pressure on the phone there is a control
of the open G file ok and if you go 93 I
have rook takes d4 so it's a tricky
tricky situation here what to do okay 93
I have looked XD 4 so what should you do
here
nice team
nice and ADT Escanaba did you know
now as you can see it's very hard to
move for white his pieces cannot move
even though he is up upon but he's got a
lot of weaknesses h2 f3h everything is
weak it's in each other he knows it's a
chest yes you're one well
96 the possibility but so what are you
trying to go with the night on v6 where
any touch
yeah it's an idea
he played c4 he tried to break open this
way so I took Knight c3 me a latina
now he goes 93 now what is the next
option here
now what should I be doing here
now what should I do here I'm still down
the pond yes you're 1h 5 is an idea
where else a tribe is interesting you're
on Rose exactly excellent thinking yes
96 now we are attacking the d4 pawn now
he goes 92 to protect it
and now that gives us an opportunity to
activate which piece
that gives you an opportunity to
activate which piece
now look Chico
now this attacks f2 yeah LC D no stop
now what to do look g2 now attacking on
f2 and h2 so he goes d5
now he decided to make a break so he
plays d5
so now what to do I don't want to take
because he has 95 right we can go back
but it's better to go here because we
want to attack on f3 back to if I'm
correct now I was look before
now the bishop is under attack
so I decided to take on f2 for a moment
leaving my bishop hanging but can you
see why can you see why I can do that
can you see why I can afford to give up
my bishop yes correct
so I took he took Roxy it quiet wolf now
I'm attacking both rooks okay so he
decided you know he cannot also play
them off King bee to do one wine 93
check fix up the roof so he cannot move
the King up because of that so it's a
little bit tricky but in the end game
you know I see there's still tactics in
the end game so he goes look c4 I took
took took and I go scheme B to C he's
not losing the knight this way but I am
getting a lot of pawns which is gonna be
important the Knights are not
particularly very strong in this
position so now which pawn we want to
capture here
correct can I do one
well that's what he wants he wants you
to take and split up your pawns I don't
want to split up my pawns so I could
push it but I want I played here putting
a would that H to pawn because if I win
the h2 pond then I can push my a Japan
as well
I could have an outside pass pawn so it
was 93 page three now look at that he
should have gone I have one here keep
the pawns but he actually he did not
have I'm sorry look at four he took I
was happy to see this capture because
now I have two connected passed pawns
and he has no past pawn rook f2
threatening to take on h2 he decided
that if he plays Knight have fun I'm
just going to continue pushing you know
so he goes here takes
now just push when you have to looks
like that very strong on a second rack
you can continue pushing the edge fun
now my plan is to play h4 and h3 just
continue pushing the edge pun Kim b1 h
494 again I don't seen it I think you
can do here so now we're gonna go for
simplification which simplification you
just have to calculate here the reason
it's good to have an outside pass fun
because it's much harder for him to stop
it okay it's much harder for him to stop
the outside passport
huh perfect he takes
just push right and he's nine he's nine
cannot get there his knife key is just
too far away from stopping the pond and
that's why I was so focused as you can
see earlier in the game to try to win
the edge fun because the central pawns
are nice but the Knights are right there
in the middle it's going to be harder to
promote the central pawns but outside
pawn I knew it it will be much easier
because then it will be very difficult
for the Knights to defend so that's why
I wanted to win the h2 point okay so
that's why I went for this position okay
in fact he probably could have defended
a little bit better and could have maybe
done something but this is probably a
very difficult position for him because
my both of my rooks are very active and
two knights are not that strong in this
kind of positions in which kind of
positions you would say the two knights
would be strong if they're more paths on
the board and the character of the
position is more closed if the character
is closed the Knights could be
dominating but you know open board like
this where you know the the Knights are
not very effective because they can only
check and in this position he cannot
even check so this is an example for you
where two knights are actually quite
weak instead of being strong here okay
and that's why I concentrate I
concentrated on winning the H pawn I
think I do believe that he should have
probably just tried to keep the night
there now the main my task a little bit
more difficult okay I'm probably still
is winning I was gonna go to cough 2 and
try to push but by by doing this he made
it easier for me no pressure on secure
and I just push perhaps he could have
maybe done something else not to allow
Roxy to but I don't see what you can do
because if you place like even Knight f1
what would be the best way to win this
game yeah I could but I can just go rook
h1 I think Knight f1 yeah yeah okay so
here I just push
so if Knight f1 see if the rook comes to
h1 putting pressure here so yeah but the
game ended as you can see like this I
took and here he resigned in fact yet
this was a very good win because it
helped us to win the finals and in the
u.s. chess league okay all right that
was the game against recently so it's a
French defense Rubinstein violation I'm
going to show you one position okay
let's see here
okay close this one we're using the new
chest pay so it works a little bit
differently than the old one let's see
okay
so we're gonna do one a bishop endgame
that's one of my favorite Bishop endgame
positions since this class is on end
games
okay we're looking this from the white
perspective we're about one squared away
from twinning okay
but it it's it's very hard to do it okay
it's very hard to do it then you have to
use a special method here to be able to
win this position because you promote
the pawn he's gonna sacrifice for it his
King is very blocking is very active so
what method we can use here to win this
game so I want to give you some time to
think so we're going to pause here for a
few minutes and see if you can find this
solution the plan for white to win this
okay we had a couple of minutes to think
so let's see if you have any thoughts
here
Johanna Bishop g5 or Bishop h4 for
example yeah what is the plan what is
the plan
okay well let's let's see let's let's
let's let's see the concrete moves bish
page for ya if I don't do anything
you're going to be able to win because
of this okay and you're going to go here
and you're going to go Bishop to b8 okay
and this is a win because you're gonna
kick the bishop from a long diagonal
you're gonna go here and then you're
gonna get him out of here with your
Bishop g1 okay so you're gonna be good
in this he takes you're gonna promote
into a quit but the problem is when you
do this he's gonna go here
and then you're gonna go check and he's
gonna go here so he's not gonna make it
he's not gonna make it easy for you to
do it
you're one
mm-hmm better
t-mike philosophy okay do we see the
plan here this next move is very very
important okay without a next move
you're not going to be able to win this
game so I want to give you a little bit
time to think here so you can find the
correct move here what is the correct
move let's see
you're on
huh nope
better
you want to control the d6 square this
is very important okay so he doesn't
have the d6 square the bishop so that
gives you an hint what might be the
first move
okay Bishop c5 again he cannot move the
King because your Bishop assembly should
be so it has to go Bishop g3 Bishop e7
now we are telling Bishop dealership c7
winning the game so it has to go here
Bishop d8 check he goes King c6 now we
go bish page for attacking the bishop if
he takes I will be eight Queen okay if
he takes I go b8 Queen gonna work so he
has to go Bishop to a7 Bishop f2 Bishop
to c5 Bishop a7 Bishop to it a seven now
it should be eight now we accomplishing
our task of removing the bishop from a
long diagonal so has to go bishop g1
bishop g3 bishop a7
and now we go Bishop to f2 and captures
we promote we finally managed to remove
the Bishop from guarding the BH square
okay so after some very important
maneuvering you're going to be able to
win this a very important endgame you
know without it you're not gonna be able
to win this game okay
when hear submission g1 here just go
here
yeah now yeah I don't think Bishop [ __ ]
yeah
well yeah I think you can get back to
the same position but I don't think
you're accomplishing the mechina I don't
think you're accomplishing that much by
playing Bishop Devon because he still
remains on the long diagonal nothing you
just made not making progress that's who
there's the hole
so that's why you need to go Bishop c5
in this position by playing Bishop g1
Bishop have to you're not damaging the
position but you're not also making any
progress
because he will stay on that diagonal in
order to do it you have to play the move
Bishop g5 to make progress okay so
that's a very important endgame for you
and a 10 will do for the final position
it was a very important King in palm
position some of you might know this
position but it's it's a it's an
excellent example of the King upon
endgame white to play and draw when
you're down upon and a king upon endgame
90 percent of the time you're very
likely you're gonna lose the game okay
down upon in it means that you're in
serious trouble but here there is a very
nice idea you have to be able to make a
draw
okay okay what's the idea
one second let's let's see king h1 the
idea of king h1 is is giving you what
kind of opposition distant opposition
okay it's a it's an odd number of
squares between both Kings so it gives
you a distant opposition here okay so
now king h1 I working d2 what do you do
to keep their opposition king h2 king d3
king h3 King III change III King e to
correct
Kinki 1
King d1 King h1 and now you just keep
doing that King be one king g1 King G 2
inches now he goes G for the last
attempt to make things complicated now
what do you do
correct
you take the e pawn it's gonna Quinn
yeah with a check and you're gonna lose
so let's say you have to go Kim G - now
I've takes takes you go King before king
e5 so it has to go King d2 and if it
does that what do we play take the pawn
he push
yeah and all right okay excellent very
good thank everybody for joining the
class and we'll be back next Tuesday
with more endgame coverage for you okay
okay all right
[Music]
you
[Music]